العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم تنقسم الى ثلاث
مدن هي الخرطوم وام درمان والخرطوم بحري
هذه المدن مجتمعه تشكل الخرطوم الكبرى
بعدد سكان يتراوح ما بين 8 الى 10 ملايين
نسمه منهم مقيمون ومنهم متنقلون اليها
يوميا للعمل وكسب الرزق والنسبه الاكبر من
السكان تقطن في مدينه الخرطوم وام درمان
الاشتباكات الجاريه حاليا متداخله في
المدن الثلاث دون وجود خط فاصل بين الجيش
وقوات التدخل السريعه في حال حدوث ما لا
تحمد عقباه واتساع رقعه القتال سيكون امام
قاطني الخرطوم طريق واحد للنزوح وهو
الجنوب تحديدا الى المدن الواقعه على
النيلين الابيض والازرق وفيما يتعلق بسكان
الخرطوم بحري امامهم التحرك شمالا او شرقا
للابتعاد عن مناطق القتال اخيرا سينبغي
على سكان ام درمان انهد دت الاوضاع
الامنيه امنهم النزوح الى المدن الواقعه
غرب وشمال وجنوب ام درمان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات